phonemes and allophones these are terms
we use to make sense of the way sounds
work in a language take just two sounds
N and M
to test if speakers hear these two
sounds is to phonemes we see if we can
find words we're switching one sound for
the other gives us a completely
different word here's the word meat
switching the M to an n gives us the
word meat this is a minimal pair the two
words differ minimally by one sound only
but what's the point of this well by
holding all the other variables constant
we can see if switching the sounds in
question changes the meaning of the word
is switching one sound for another
changes the meaning it follows that
we're looking at two different words and
if there are two different words English
speakers treat the two sounds in
question as different sounds
in this example and an M are contrasted
and this contrast tells us that M and M
are two distinct phonemes in English a
phoneme can have different
pronunciations take this out K it comes
out with a puff of air in the word kite
but not in the word sky these two sounds
and are different but we hear them as
variants of the same sound we call these
and allophones
of the phoneme k
the same goes for M and M in the word
input I've heard that word pronounced
both input and input making mmm and mmm
variants of the same sound allophones of
the phoneme M the sounds and show up in
different places after s we hear only
sky scans skirt but at the beginning of
a word we hear can keep cool
these allophones show up in different
environments where we find one we won't
find the other and vice versa that kind
of mutually exclusive relationship is
called complementary distribution other
allophones sounds can show up in the
same environment go back to the word
input input varies with input in a
tomato tomahto sort of way these two
allophones of the phoneme n are in free
variation with one
this last example shows you that one
sound like mmm might show up best
allophones of multiple phonemes mmm is
how people usually pronounce the phoneme
em but it's also how some people
pronounce the phoneme n in the word
input in the next lesson I'll build on
the concepts of phoneme and alle phone
and begin working through the
pronunciation system of a foreign
language as we do that I'll help you
uncover all the basics of phonology
you